and joining me now Republican
Congressman Matt Gates and the co-host
of the five Geraldo Rivera Geraldo I've
known you a long time please please
don't raise my blood pressure uh it's
it's almost Friday
but please tell me something Matt Gates
and you don't want me to raise your
blood pressure oh Geraldo okay well
we're going to give Matt a chance to
respond in a minute but please tell me
you're not going to let Fang Fang's
boyfriend you're not going to stick up
for him to be on the Intel committee uh
neither he nor ship in my view should
even be able to get a classified
anything in the private sector never
mind the government Adam Schiff is a
proven liar he used his position on the
Intel committee and he lied to the
American people and I know that he lied
because for almost three years nightly
on this show we exposed his lies and the
things that he was doing in the Intel
community weaponizing and politicizing
information by tell telling the American
people things that just weren't true are
you supporting these two guys
I am not and the reason is when speaker
Pelosi deemed that Jim Banks and Jim
Jordan were unsuitable to be on the
January 6 committee that to me was a
kind of political Vengeance that now uh
good for the goose good for the gander
the fact that McCarthy is doing it now
they should have known that it's just a
matter of time political Cycles work
their way through and then if you did it
to me I'm going to do it back to you
what I am absolutely outraged by though
is how this new Congress is just just
the reflection of the last Congress it's
a do-nothing congress what are what in
the world are they there for Matt Gates
why are you pursuing uh you know Adam
Schiff and and passing legislation to
get him uh you know barred from
intelligence to protect the country
paycheck protection fraud and some of
those other the meaningful things for
the American people things they care
about their their pocketbook you know
they they care about their safety I go
after real issues Matt
well I I think that if you look at the
work of the House of Representatives
today we were passing legislation to
stop Joe Biden from playing politics
with the Strategic petroleum reserve and
you're absolutely right we ought to
pursue clawbacks where there was fraud
in a lot of these programs and we ought
to do that before raising the debt limit
we ought to impose work requirements so
I don't I'll invite you here although
you could take my guest pass and come
observe a Congress that is quite
different from the last Congress if for
no other reason than during the battle
for the speakership we demanded open
rules open amendments today we took
votes on over 20 amendments some by
democrats some by Republicans but
certainly no one can defend Adam Schiff
and Eric swalwell these are people who
made careers leaking and then
embroidering lies onto those very leaks
and Adam Schiff doesn't just go on Tick
Tock to publish information a real
critique we have is that for three years
when Republicans wanted access to
intelligence about the origins of the
coronavirus Adam shift was essentially
the blocking tackle for the Chinese
Communist party and did not get that
information out in front of the public
now he's a congressman Congressman you
you play you sound a good game what in
the world were you in your 19 colleagues
doing torturing the speaker your speaker
your speaker designate Kevin McCarthy
Eagle News what was that for what was
what did you what did you hope to attain
in that
so first of all I got some constituents
in the military that could talk to you
about real torture I don't think sitting
through 15 votes quite qualifies but
here's what we were fighting for we
believe that instead of having Omnibus
spending legislation that comes to us
with only a few hours to consider
thousands of pages and then vote on
something that funds every agency of the
gum of the government all or once that
we should take individual votes on
Appropriations bills that's a concession
we didn't have when voting began it's
one we earned by the time it ended we
also believe that when bills are
considered they should comport to a
single subject so I don't have to do
what I've had to do in the past and vote
on the farm bill at the same time you're
voting on whether or not there's going
to be War Powers in Yemen we also wanted
open amendments so Republicans Or
democrats could offer Germaine
adjustments to legislation and everyone
could take votes on these things you
know members of Congress speakers they
come and go but when rules
with your filibuster right now you are
you are portraying yourself to the
American people as a as a as a
thoughtful legislator and yet the the
publicity that you get
characteristically almost inevitably is
is flamboyant it's uh it's
confrontational
substantive argument about changes to
the process and you call me it's a
conversational question he answered your
very specific question about what he was
fighting for my only argument and Matt
and I talked a lot in December Matt you
can verify this is true my only my only
beef with everybody was I wanted
everybody to be in full agreement by
January 3rd four days it came it went
and now everybody's on the same page he
gave you very specific arguments about
what he was fighting for how the this
Congress is different and better than
the last one why are you attacking him
personally
well I I I thought that's why you
invited me Sean you were attacking the
person always to knows with your
right-wing Champion I'm here I don't
even defend themselves I don't know I
don't know I mean I I don't know you I I
all I know is what I read in the
newspapers I appreciate that that's got
to be true I
like it changes
will Republicans come together on the
debt ceiling and will they stand strong
at 222 because Biden is betting against
that that's why he says no negotiation
well if we pick the right fight I
want bacon
instead he believed that no cuts and
entitlements could ever be acceptable to
his wing of the Republican party I
actually think we should have work
requirements if we imposed work
requirements on snap and on Medicaid
expansion
adults we would have the ability to save
one trillion dollars
three children
make her work
yeah and you know what you can meet work
requirements in a lot of these states by
volunteering at non-profits by helping
out at a local church
services
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else